la fiscalía de Guatemala le solicitó
expresamente al secretario de estado de
los Estados Unidos Anthony blinken que
evite indebidas interpretaciones luego
del comunicado que el departamento de
estado publicó en el que se subraya una
persecución a los periodistas en
Guatemala el departamento de estado de
Estados Unidos por cuenta de su portavoz
net price había manifestado el pasado
jueves estar profundamente preocupado
dada la criminalización del trabajo de
los periodistas que en sus palabras
socaba la democracia y el derecho a la
libertad de expresión pero la fiscalía
que dirige Consuelo porras de quien
valga decir está acusada y señalada por
Estados Unidos en la lista de Engel por
favorecer la corrupción dijo que el caso
en el que se va a investigar a nueve
periodistas se va a mantener en completa
reserva y que Estados Unidos no se debe
dejar sorprender por información que no
sea estrictamente oficial El caso en
cuestión corresponde a la orden de un
juez guatemalteco esta semana
investigara nueve periodistas que
presuntamente por sus publicaciones
habrían viciado el proceso penal en
contra de José Rubén Zamora el
periodista internacionalmente premiado
que se encuentra acusado de lavado de
dinero entre otros delitos pero que
según él su encarcelamiento se debe a
las investigaciones que realizó en
contra de los corruptos en Guatemala
incluyendo aquellas que relacionan al
presidente Alejandro ya